انضم الينا من كيف تترواه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي وتنضم الينا من موسكو الينا
سبولينا الكاتبه والمحلله السياسيه وابدا
معك السيده وكان المشهد انقلب فيما يؤكد
الجانب الروسي حرصه على ان باب التفاوض ما
زال مفتوحا الجانب الان هو من يقول لن
يكون هناك جلوس لطاوله المفاوضات حتى
استعاده الحدود التاريخيه ما قبل سنه 91
من الجانب الروسي الذي يحدث
مساء الخير الذي يحدث انه روسيا مستعده
للتفاوض
والقاده الرؤوس الان
خفقوا لهجتهم واتجاهها لازمه في اوكرانيا
بشكل ملحوظ هناك
مؤشرات ورسائل عندي ان روسيا مستعد لهذا
التفاوض واكثر من ذلك قد بدات الاتصالات
ما بين روسيا وامريكا يقال انه هذه
الاتصالات كانها ليست حول الملف
الاوكرانيا ولكنني متاكده هو اكثر من ذلك
اعرف تماما انه يتم تطرق للملف والاكراني
من خلال هذه الاتصالات واللقاءات نعم يمكن
الاولويه الان في العلاقات ما بين الروسيا
وامريكا انه هناك الحديث حول تبادل
السجناء وايضا يتم تحضير الان للقاءات
مهمه حول اسلحه استراتيجيه ممكن ان تنعقد
هذه الجلسات في نهايه نوفمبر في ظاهره
واحه استمر
بضعه همم ولكن عبر هذه اللقاءات واتصالات
روسيا تبعت رسائل دول العرب عنده
المفاوضات ممكن
فالمشكله انه اوكرانيا الان غير مستعد الى
هذا الشيء وانا حسب تقديره الحكومه
الاوكرانيه ترتكب بخطا كبير الان
ما رايك يا سيد همم اوف سكي يعني كما قالت
السيده الينا سبونينا في روسيا يبدو وكانه
هناك تقاربا غربيا اوكرانيا عفوا روسيا
يجري الاعداد له همم هل من مصلحه اوكرانيا
اليوم طرح هذه الشروط عاليه السقف همم
للدخول في المفاوضات
في الحقيقه
المشاهدين الكرام
والطيفه من موسكو ان البيان الصادر عن
الدول العشرين
دانا القوات الروسيه دانا روسيا على غزوه
اوكرانيا باضافه الى التاثير الذي حصل على
مستوى الاقتصاد الدولي وايضا وقع هذا
الغزو على امن الغذاء في العالم وايضا
اتفاق الحبوب
وتاثير الذي لحق به وبالتالي يجب ان نتذكر
هذه النقطه لقد دانا العالم الاعتداء
الروسي حتى الصين انضمت الى هذا البيان
وبالتالي بشكل مبدئي الدول الكبرى في
العالم بما في ذلك الصين والهند اتفقت مع
اوكرانيا وحتى الصين قالت ان سلامه اراضي
الدول يجب ان تحفظ وتوسان وتحترم وبالتالي
هذا يعني ان المفاوضات لا يمكن ان تبدا
الا بعد سحب روسيا كل قواتها من اوكرانيا
وهذا المطلب يواجهه الى روسيا لا يمكن
التفاوض قبل سحب القوات الروسيه وهذا
الموقف توافقوا عليه الاقتصادات الكبرى في
العالم
المرتفع من تصريحات من قبل المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين ان هناك خشيه حقيقيه لدى كياف
ان هناك امرا يتم في اتجاه التفاوض لذلك
تصاعد في هذه اللهجه وربما ايضا عن ذلك ما
قاله الجانب الروسي ان حتى الصواريخ التي
سقطت في بولندا انما هي
محاوله من قبال كيفوريه روسيا مع النيته
وبالتالي استمرار الحرب
في الحقيقه يجب ان نفهم ان ما حصل في
بولندا كان نتيجه
للاعتداء الروسي على اوكرانيا وبالتالي لم
تصل التحقيقات الى خواتيمها بالنسبه الى
ما حصل في بولندا ولكن روسيا اطلقت 96
صاروخا في ذلك اليوم الاستهدافي اوكرانيا
بالحديث عن المفاوضات يجب ان نتذكر ان
هناك مفاوضات او مباحثات بين اداره
الاستخبارات المركزيه السي اي اي وايضا
الاستخبارات الروسيه في انقره وبعد هذه
المباحثات اتى المدير الى كيف وتناقش بهذه
الامور بشكل
سريع مع اوكرانيا ولكن في اجتماعي
وايضا الغرب همم نعرف ان الغرب رفع
المساعده العسكريه لاوكرانيا وهذا يعني
بالتالي ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم
تؤدي الى اشارات معاديه او معاكسه
ان احد شروطها هو خروج كافه القوات
الروسيه من جميع الاراضي الاوكرانيه الا
يبدو هذا الطلب الان اكثر منطقيا بالنظر
الى التراجع التي تبنى به موسكو في ارض
الميدان لا سيما ما حدث في خرسان
ابدا حسب معلوماتي روسيا لديها امكانيات
عسكريه جيده
والان من خلال هذا الفاصل الروسيه ممكن ان
تتحضر بشكل جيد له هجومات في مناطق عده
وحتى رغم الانتخاب الروسي من منطقه حرسان
هناك تقدم في مدن صغيره اخرى
ممكن ان ترد على اوكرانيا اذا ما قبلت
القياده الاوكرانيه فكره التفاوض
بالنسبه لبيان قمه عشرين فهو كان بيان
مشترك ووزير خارجيه روسيا كان موجود هناك
هناك
يشير الى انه ليست كل الدول الحاضره كانت
موافقه على مثل هذه اولا وثانيا البيان
وهو يدين حاله الحرب هذا يعني انه الرفضك
رانيا لفكره المفا حتى هو
يحملها المسؤوليه على اطاله هذه الازمه
هذا الرابط هو خاطئ جدا لانه فيما بعد
اوكرانيا ممكن ان تخسر اكثر اكثر وانا ان-
لي ان يتابعوا ماذا يقول الجمهوريون في
امريكا شكرا لك الينا سبونينا الكاتبه
والمحلله السياسيه همم من موسكو وشكرا من
ثياب يترو بالكوفسكي الكاتب عفوا من كيف
نعم نعم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي